without energy there's no heat okay or
cold because air conditioning sure
depends on it too
so
what we have here is if even though you
might not think climate change is an
important issue and i don't either as a
matter of fact because i don't know if i
can do anything about it i think it's a
top ten i don't think it's number one no
it's it well it's a top ten in people's
minds but the the real issue is energy
because the the climate policy that is
being adopted that's a better word i'm
with you there i'm more on the energy
side but we have to pay attention to
this because yes if we don't pay
attention to this this could be an issue
in the next 200 years but the it's the
energy side that will that i'm talking
about being basically a suicide pact
this net zero thing and
the whole idea that we can end the use
of fossil fuels without increasing
nuclear energy because the same people
who are against all fossil fuel use are
also against all nuclear energy and that
is the only technology that that can
actually replace fossil fuels as a
reliable source 24 7. hydroelectric is
just as good except there's flat places
and dry places where there can't be any
hydroelectric energy whereas nuclear is
can be used anywhere from the north pole
to the equator out on the oceans on a
barge you can put nuclear energy
anywhere in the world all you need to do
is cool it with water or air and you can
have it there then the russians are
floating barges down the rivers from the
north in the arctic to the some of the
cities that don't have a grid that are
way up north like they've purposely
developed up there
and they're bringing nuclear reactors in
there russia china and india are all way
ahead of the united states now in
nuclear reactor technology
and britain is even further ahead too in
many ways there they've got uh
boeing there and not boeing sorry
uh i'm trying to think of other people
who make
really expensive cars
um
what is the most expensive british car
rolls royce yes it's rolls royce that
has been building the submarine nuclear
engines for
uh uk fleet for 60 years or more they
know how to do it and so the fact the
matter is
we could replace 50 percent of the
fossil fuels in the next 30 years or 40
years with nuclear energy with no
difficulty at all but the idea that wind
and solar are going to replace fossil
fuels or nuclear or hydroelectric
is absolutely insane can i just explain
a little bit
when you have wind and solar you have at
most one-third of the of the time can
you produce reliable energy the sun goes
down all night it's no good early in the
morning or the afternoon and then the
clouds come
right so solar energy is more like 20
percent capacity
so so 80 of the time it can't serve the
grid which is a demand for energy at
certain times a day a certain amount the
same with wind the wind stops at night
the wind stops in the summer the wind
stops in the winter the wind stops for
two weeks at a time
the wind stops when the propellers
freeze up the wind stops when the wind
wind blows too fast because they have to
tether the blades
and so if you're going to use batteries
instead of gas
or coal or nuclear
to back up
the wind and solar
you have to build three times as much
capacity
in production in other words if you need
a hundred megawatts
of
coal energy you need 300 megawatts
capacity of wind and solar energy to
charge the batteries because you can't
charge the batteries when the wind isn't
blowing and the sun isn't shining but at
the same time as you're charging the
batteries you have to be supplying the
grid with the full amount of energy that
it needs
so there's no technical feasibility
study on this there's no economic
feasibility study on this mark mills of
the manhattan institute in new york is
the expert he's written three or four
recent papers on how much material it's
going to take in terms of cement the
wind industry
uses more than 100 times as much cement
per unit of power produced as gas does
a hundred times more cement so the
amount of fossil fuels that are required
to build the wind and solar
infrastructure
makes wind and solar a parasite on the
larger economy
that is a fair metaphor a parasite in
other words it's sucking
wealth out of the system in order to
support this stupid idea that wind and
solar are renewable yes the sun is
renewable and the wind is renewable but
the infrastructure is not
the stuff they build isn't made out of
plants it's made out of steel and
concrete and cadmium and aluminum and
glass and lithium and cobalt and all
these things and if you look at the
amount of material that has to go in to
a wind turbine
compared to a gas plant it's phenomenal
it means they have to mine vast amounts
of ore and truck all this stuff
everywhere huge machinery to put these
things up and build them so i've said
that all the wind and solar
infrastructure onshore and offshore
should have to be built with wind and
solar energy
in other words they should not be
allowed to use fossil fuels
or nuclear or hydroelectric
power to build the wind and solar
infrastructure and then see how fast it
disappears it would be wiped off the
face of the earth and
and goodly so because it is a parasite
and all these people are getting rich
all the crony capitalists are getting
rich off the subsidies their first there
are subsidies then there are tax breaks
then there are mandates by utilities
that politically are forcing the
people to take the wind and solar when
it's available even though it costs more
than the other
technologies it's a total mess and this
is the part of climate change that is
worth paying attention to the science of
climate change i cover it in my book
thoroughly fake invisible catastrophes
and threats of doom
the main reason that we have all these
scare stories today is because there are
a lot of things that are either
invisible carbon dioxide radiation
whatever is supposed to be bad in gmos
which actually doesn't exist because it
doesn't have a name or a chemical
formula so therefore it's fake but co2
and radiation aren't fake they're just
invisible so no one can see what they're
doing
then you have the remote things polar
why are polar bears and coral reefs the
main icons here because no one can see
what they're doing
right so they say 93 percent of the
great barrier reef is nearly dead is
practically dead
is bleached is in its final terminal
stage none of those mean dead
of course they just they they make it
like practically dead it means it's
going to die right no no it doesn't
things come back from being practically
dead like coral reefs
and they weren't practically dead in the
first place that was all hypen anyways
polar bear population has grown by four
to five times in the last 50 years
i ask big audiences of professional
people how many of you have heard of the
international treaty signed in 1973 by
all the polar nations
ending the unrestricted hunting of polar
bears
no one's ever heard of it no one ever
talks about it they don't want you to
know about that because that treaty on
the advice of wildlife biologists to the
leaders of those countries around the
pole
that has caused a three to five times
increase in polar bear populations to
this day where now the people who live
up in the polar bear region in canada
it's nunavut and then it's green land in
norway
those people in nunavut
which is canada has the most polar bears
of anybody because we have so many
islands up there in the arctic
those people have passed a polar bear
management plan two years ago because
they think there's too many polar bears
because they're eating people and
and they are breaking into houses and
there there's just too many of them
they've grown so much and yet not one
newspaper in canada or the united states
reported that polar bear management plan
or report the treaty that was signed in
1973. so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]